trump ha regresado a la casa blanca tras
ser internado por su contagio de kobe 19
pero todo se tornó diferente la sala de
prensa un lugar frecuentemente lleno de
personas se muestra sin reporteros allí
se observa el personal de limpieza bajo
fuertes medidas de protección
desinfectando el área y es que los casos
entre los allegados al donald trump
siguen en aumento stephen miller uno de
los asesores del presidente fue el
último confirmado por kobe 19
trump también informado que otros
funcionarios republicanos están
afectados por la enfermedad para el
doctor anthony fauci el brote de la casa
blanca se habría evitado con controles
más estrictos y pues nada ya no se hizo
de acuerdo con las recomendaciones es
decir lo que se vio en la casa blanca
esa imagen desde arriba con todos los
aglomerados sin máscaras eso no se hizo
de acuerdo con lo que hubiera
recomendado
tras su regreso a la casa blanca- donald
trump mantiene un poderoso cóctel de
drogas como tratamiento pero ha señalado
su disposición de participar en el
próximo debate presidencial
joe biden su rival político pidió no
tomar el virus común
armand política y ha pedido a trump que
transmita el mensaje correcto sobre la
enfermedad
en lugar de hablar lo único que escuché
fue un tweet que decía no te preocupes
por todo esto hay mucho de qué
preocuparse 210 mil personas han muerto
respecto al debate sostiene que este
evento debe cancelarse dato el contagio
del presidente